tras la llamada telefónica del martes el
presidente estadounidense joe biden y su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin acordaron
mantener el tratado de desarme nuclear
new star aunque la decisión no se
formalizó hasta que la duma rusa dio el
visto bueno este miércoles a la
prolongación del pacto por cinco años
una garantía de paz entre ambas naciones
la administración de baden ya había
informado de su intención de alargar en
new star poco después de la toma de
poder del demócrata
acabo de mencionar mi conversación con
el presidente de byd en ayer y la
ampliación del tratado start
esto es definitivamente un paso en la
dirección correcta
para el histórico tratado se firmó en
praga en 2010 entre los entonces
presidentes de eeuu barack obama y el de
rusia dmitri medvéved este tratado
limita el número de armas nucleares
estratégicas a 1.550 cabezas nucleares
de 700 sistemas balísticos prohíbe su
uso fuera de los territorios nacionales
y también incluye la revisión período
de las instalaciones militares para
asegurarse del mutuo cumplimiento del
desarme ambos países líderes en
armamento nuclear desde la guerra fría
se dirigieron al acuerdo para limitar el
uso del arsenal atómico ampliamente
destructivo el anterior ejecutivo de
donald trump insistió en la
participación de china en el pacto pero
rusia se negó y solo se mostró abierta a
incluir a las también potencias
nucleares del reino unido y francia-
esta decisión podría ser un paso
adelante en las relaciones entre moscú y
washington cuyos lazos se han
deteriorado en los últimos años